hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here is a tremendous puzzle
send plus more is equal to money
you have to solve for each letter where
each letter is a distinct digit
m is not equal to zero and the solution
is unique
i also want to thank everyone who
suggested this problem to me
it includes the following people
darren from oklahoma mark from tennessee
as well as ryan and james camp from
texas
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so before i get to the answer i highly
encourage you to work this problem out
it took me about 30 minutes to work
through the cases carefully and then
devise a way to explain it
logical puzzles like this will improve
your number sense and you can only get
better with practice
so how can we solve this
we'll start with the fifth column
since the resulting sum is a five digit
number
and the largest sum we can produce is
nine nine nine nine plus nine nine nine
nine which is less than twenty thousand
we can conclude m is equal to one
so we already have one of the digits
which takes two spots in this summation
now we look at the fourth column
we again use the same sort of argument
since the largest three digit sum we can
produce is nine nine nine plus nine nine
nine which is less than two thousand
column three either gives a zero carry
over or it gives a one carry over to the
fourth column
so we can work through the cases
if there's no carryover we have s plus
one is equal to ten plus o
this would imply that s is equal to nine
plus o
in the other case where we have a one
carry over we have one plus s plus one
is equal to ten plus o
and this implies that s is equal to 8
plus o
since s is a single digit we must have o
is equal to 0
or o is equal to 1.
anything larger would produce something
larger than nine
now since m is equal to one we can't
have o be equal to one therefore o must
be equal to zero
so we figured out another digit
now we'll look at the third column
since e cannot be equal to n because
each of the letters is a distinct digit
we cannot have e plus 0 is equal to n
we must have 1 plus e is equal to n
in other words there must be carry over
from column 2.
now since n cannot be equal to 0 we must
have e is less than 9.
consequently column 3 cannot produce any
carry over to column 4.
so we're going to look at column 4 again
and we must have s plus 1 is equal to 10
which means s is equal to 9. so we
figured out another digit
now we look at the second column
there must be carryover from this column
into the third column
so we must have n plus r is equal to 10
plus e
or if there's carry over from the first
column we have one plus n plus r is
equal to 10 plus e
so let's work through the first case
since we have 1 plus e is equal to n we
can substitute that in for n
we have 1 plus e plus r is equal to 10
plus e
this would imply that r is equal to 9.
however
we cannot have r equal to nine because s
is equal to nine so we eliminate this
possibility
so we solve the second case
this implies that one plus one plus e
plus r is equal to ten plus e
which then implies r is equal to eight
so we figured out another digit and
furthermore
since we're in this case
this means there must be carryover from
column one because we have one plus n
plus r
so we'll keep track of all this
and we have r is equal to eight and we
know that there must be carryover from
column one
so we look at column one
since y cannot equal zero or one those
digits are already used we must have d
plus e is greater than or equal to 12.
now since d and e cannot be equal to 8
or 9 because those digits are used
we only have a couple possibilities we
could either have 7 plus 5 is equal to
12 or we could have 7 plus 6 which is
equal to 13.
so one of the digits
e is equal to 7 or d is equal to 7.
now suppose that e is equal to seven
in that case e plus one will be equal to
eight which is equal to n
but this is not possible since r is
equal to eight
so we can eliminate that e is equal to
7.
this means d is equal to 7 which means e
is equal to 5 or 6
because 7 plus 5 is equal to 12 or 7
plus 6 is equal to 13.
so what would happen if e is equal to
five or six well suppose e is equal to
six in that case e plus one is seven
which would be equal to n but this is
not possible because d is already equal
to seven
so we must have e is equal to five
which means e plus one is equal to six
which is equal to n
finally
we have seven plus e which will be equal
to seven plus five which equals twelve
so this means y is equal to two
and we figured it out
we have e is equal to five n is equal to
six and y is equal to two and we've
solved that this puzzle sen plus more is
equal to money has a solution
9567 plus 1085
is equal to 10
652.
it's an incredible puzzle since there is
just a single solution and you can work
through it very carefully with basic
arithmetic
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos
you can email me a puzzle or math topic
presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support